il a des allures de cockpit
ce robot chirurgical nouvelle génération
a rejoint la clinique privée des
franciscaines à versailles d'avancé ici
c'est son nom permet d'offrir de
meilleures conditions d'hospitalisation
pour les patients mais aussi pour les
chirurgiens pour le docteur g ne vois
c'est une première beaucoup moins
fatigués au lieu de rester deux à trois
heures debout en tenant des instruments
donc les épaules un peu surélevé
là on est assis à la console du robot et
puis on a voilà on est moins crispés sur
les pinces
on a une liberté de mouvement qui est
sans équivalent en coelioscopie et une
vision en trois dimensions qui fatiguent
beaucoup moins cette patiente souffrait
d'une descente d'organes avec ses bras
et ses pinces articuler le robot a
permis d'accrocher plus facilement des
bandelettes pour stopper la maladie à
l'origine utilisés dans la chirurgie
urologique
ce robot peut aussi être utile en
gynécologie le docteur applebaum
l'utilisent chaque semaine depuis le
début de l'année c'est un vrai plus pour
le patient en terme de ce qu'on appelle
la réhabilitation précoce j'ai vraiment
l'impression que les patientes sont
beaucoup plus confortable
j'aime une courbe d'apprentissage parce
que c'est vraiment une technique
nouvelle qui s'est tout à fait bien
déroulée et qui me permet dès maintenant
faite d'accéder à des cas difficiles
j'ai vraiment l'impression que le geste
est plus simple dans les cas difficiles
seul inconvénient à prendre cette
nouvelle technique et le coût pour les
hôpitaux
le premier robot arrivé il ya sept ans à
la clinique a été remplacé par ce modèle
à 2 millions d'euros
il en existe seulement 120 dans toute la
france